maintenant je n'étais pas quelqu'un
qu'on oublie ça va faire 30 ans de 20,1
maman t'a jamais pensé que vous avez
peut-être pas tout raconter sur la mort
de maman des fois ça fait du bien de se
retrouver salle je suis sûr c'est
arrêter les défis je me suis dit qu'on
voit peut-être se faire un petit
week-end entre frère et soeur parce que
je vous emmènerai alors moutier monsieur
c'est là qu'on a retrouvé son corps sur
la plage
ah non mais c'est pas là qu'on a
retrouvé votre c'était l'autre côté de
la baie j'aimerais savoir quoi bah je
sais pas des trucs sur maman qu'est ce
qui t'a pris dalenc et tu ta grand mère
je sais que c'est un sujet qui leur mue
et klein je vais me disant ça me touche
que tu t'intéresses à moi comme ça ma
soeur dit que je suis parano
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec ma mère
le 29 août 1984 et tu t'interroges sur
cette poule est à 30 ans après c'est
légitime
là ça devient carrément délirant toile
je suis désolé oddo note en dessous si
pardon
à
liste on se parle on se parle pas mal
j'en peux plus de moi toute l'histoire
cela empêche d'avancer
pourquoi c'est si tabou dans une famille
d'avoir raison
départ de faire passer pour un dingue
trop tôt
c'est quoi ces choses qu'on garde pour
soi
un jour ça se paye
mais avec le temps ça vous coupe des
autres